hello mr head of government
i am delighted to be in morocco for my
first visit as president of
the european commission and i am
particularly delighted with
the warm and fruitful meeting that
i had with you mr head of
government
allow me first of all as a
friend of the moroccan movement to convey my
condolences to the parents of little ryan
and through you, mr head of
government, to all the moroccan people
the whole world held its breath in the
face of this tragedy
admire the efforts  superhuman
rescuers and mourn the tragic outcome
we stand by your side in this
difficult time he we stand by your
side especially since Morocco is a country
with which we have built a
close and solid strategic partnership our ties are
indeed historic
if we talk about economy and trade it
is important to underline that morocco
is the first partner of the
european union on the  whole of
the African continent storyteller but beyond
the economy it is above all a question of the personal links
of Europeans settled in
Morocco and Moroccans in Europe of our
cultures who have influenced and
enriched each other for centuries
and it is with all this  in mind that I
can reaffirm our desire to
continue to deepen our relations
as a
neighbor as a partner as a friend
I was able to see during our
conversation Mr. Head of
Government
that this reciprocal desire
is therefore together  that we can
build a common and ambitious vision
of our partnership
we were able to discuss the many
global challenges facing Morocco
and Europe in
order to meet them we must find
solutions together
within the framework of our partnership
allow me first  the main ones
to address the main topics
of common interest
we are working towards developing a
partnership
towards between the mar  oc and the european union this
is the first one we are developing
with a partner country
this will also allow
us to engage together in the
development of our greener energy
we are also cooperating to strengthen
the connectivity of our societies,
including through the  broad digital partnership a
lot can be done to
further integrate our economies and better
adapt them
it will be to the benefit of our companies,
esp their employees and all
workers
in this context I would like to emphasize
the attention we pay to the role of
young people
and their crucial contribution to the progress
of our societies as well as to the efforts
we must make to offer them the
best future the best possible future
this is why we reserve an
important place for education and
culture  in our
bilateral cooperation,
I am delighted that the ambitious vision
defined for Morocco in your
established development models  under the
direction of his majesty the king
echoes many of his ambitions and
common objectives finally beyond our
bilateral cooperation
we are also counting on you in the
implementation of the new agenda for the
mediterranean as you can see the
subjects to be explored together  are really
numerous
I wish to continue this dialogue with
you in the future Mr. Head of
Government and thank you for
your hospitality
during this first meeting thank you
very much
for
your bath
since the
gym said you will not be from the estrie
named enough  to have
islamophobia
da and in nîmes
the
new cameras of
the sunshine infiniti maya in the end if
dice to a friend to say of
the offer of ge went to kyra in the case
of eric cantona it means that they
moliets final  in attack on the right that
he only has some of which there is a
myth that loubna al awar such the debt
he wins is a hymn to shakhtar a
feeling stormy climate
musharraf he estimated opens the
robust economic balance rebels inch'allah
in short you will have scherick strategy he
pulled in the country the nama has moreover
the winger with the cobras the nama monster
beautiful speckled rack or the evil senate
charles lapicque to the legitimate
even the nao
millions of euros nataka  and tirades
case charles lynch is nothing